okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is one of our infinite
series of language completeness and
consistency meetings about of language
and we have a variety of things here
that look a little bit on the detailed
side but we'll take a look and see
what's happening
okay second argument to head that is a
thirst while long running function and
how could it have never had a second
argument and getting one now let's see
what it does is oh it's a holding
argument and things is that right
yes so we can do this here but we can't
do it we can do it for extract and we
can't but we can't do it for by the way
it's a little bit strange that this
doesn't refer to extract um and arguably
head should also refer to things like
curry don't you think
oh yeah I think so we're discussing
yesterday about using examples memory in
this page okay
can I um can I edit this page or not you
can edit this page
okay so if I should mention extract here
shouldn't we yes and we should probably
mention curry and we should arguably
mention um construct as well
and I don't have any problem with that
let's assume that's that's okay all
right
did you try that okay I I think we
should point out the fact that
expressions have their head typically
already evaluated so this is going to be
useful in the case in which the first
argument to head is passed with
unevaluated around I see I see it's
important in typesetting and that's why
it I and other people doing typesetting
want it and I understand that but it's a
relatively strange case I see I see I
see right boy does this have no no
details here nope okay yeah you should
absolutely point that out otherwise it's
completely obscure mixing like
extraction with a replacement though
isn't in the same head is like part the
part of expression comma zero and that's
like replace head the second one no it's
not it wraps the result with H so it it
takes the result which might otherwise
explode because you go what I'm saying
mark their future iced examples if you
wanna you know look at something
concrete right that's the relevant
example right because that that holds
that head otherwise what would happen is
the inverse function of sine would
evaluate exactly
right see that mark yeah but it doesn't
just hold the head it holds the whole
expression no it doesn't it's the head
structurally and then holds the holds
the because that of one hasn't been put
in there this is a corner case okay but
but you know if it's useful it's useful
and let's do it okay it's it's
distinctly a goner case okay nothing
more to say about this nope okay is it
actually consistent with what happens
with I mean with things like first we're
doing the second argument is then a and
if it doesn't have that element do this
right right but nothing can we without
its head so to speak
exactly okay all right head versus part
zero oh my gosh you know somebody's
making a lot of noise you could not do
that that'd be great
okay so I mean I explained how we
entered we got here right so I mean this
is arguably consistent with the
documentation right if part extracts or
specified parts rather than words I
agree I agree
those first two don't seem obviously
horrifying okay so the numeric array
ones I can't comment on because I don't
know though
okay what is the question here well the
question is so the question is which way
and
do we want to extend the sparser a
behavior to all s types or do we want
head to you know or do we want to change
parts here I don't know like head
I don't think vallata I don't think -
well I think this is good but I don't
know how many of these lists like things
there are and I don't know without
looking at each one I don't know exactly
what should be done that right so
basically the list is sparse array
structured array currently returns and
evaluated but presumably should behave
the same a sparse array and we mean
structured array returns unevaluated I
mean that if you try to compute part of
0 of a symmetrized array or a quantity
array you will it will yell at you and
return and evaluate it which I thought
oh yeah that's just wrong ok so that's
this thing and then if I now say here if
I give a particular element right but if
you put a if you put 0 in there then it
will yell or I guess just silently
return on the value yeah I think that's
wrong yes I think that that should be an
as if list result okay
okay now I think it is a little weird to
break the and we should make sure the
documentation is clear on you know and
makes the footnote about these cases but
I think it's okay that head is a
structural thing and zero I mean it's a
little weird but right I mean this
behavior is not useful correct
right so I mean my point of view unless
somebody objects violently to this I
think that the status quo for sparse
array is okay okay it should be extended
anybody object violently to that
I mean why is list a reasonable answer
for the zeros cart a sparse array I mean
a list isn't even an array its ragged
representation next birth isn't age
because it's the as if the sparse array
is behaving as if it is it's normal
right but it's potentially confusing in
comparison with pattern matching with so
that is not going to match underscore
list that's true so I think you know
I'll be more consistent to to just admit
it's a sparse round object given in part
0 this unsub non 0 subpart I mean let me
point out in terms of pattern matching
if I say I suit you're saying okay well
that's an argument to not do this to
have that returned sparse array now why
does why do we feel strongly that that
should return list
I don't know that anybody feels strongly
that it should return list I'm just
saying this is I think how we got into
this situation all right well let's look
at the other case the case where this
the zero thing there returns
sparse array now the slippery slope
there is clearly any nonzero part
extractor returns I mean is there a
heads option so so here's where it could
get really funky right I mean if I say
level if I say level of that comma one
for example I don't even understand that
at all I don't understand that at all
perhaps you need Hedstrom know but I'm
not looking for the head I'm looking for
the I'm looking for I'm just anything
that has okay I'm completely confused by
that because this is if we unspecified
us well okay so what is that that is a
that is that and if we unspecified it
will be just that list so I'm assuming
that the level says null because it's
somehow a no entry object in it is Adam
Q
okay other than that's sort of weird
with the part stuff so maybe ignore that
that's it that's it I know it's more
weirdness okay look this seems to be to
me right because that's doing a match to
the head
what this does seems a bit undefined
right and I do have the example of down
below of if you take part 1 of a matrix
sparse array then you get a sparse array
out so you know we could but what would
you have get out no you can't get out I
mean that would kind of suggest the way
you should get but but if you go to two
levels there then you'll get a number
so what do you conclude from that well I
guess what I conclude from this is that
it you know we don't literally return
exactly what the normal representation
would return right so we it wouldn't be
crazy to return sparser II but so for
example if he then did you know one zero
right listen we're shooting in the dark
here we don't know because first of all
that's inventory all the functions that
this effects okay for which I'm
understanding structured array and
symmetrized array will be to others
any others than those so the ones
there's currently effects are sparse
array symmetry store a quantity array
numeric array and binary byte array yes
well practice byte array do with this if
I say byte array of range 10 and then I
say that sub 4 oh wow I didn't know that
worked so ok percent 173 sub 0
oh that's just weird
that's just weird ok my head is spinning
so to speak I don't know what to do here
ok let's get let's get an inventory of
all of these things and then let's try
to think through you you've brought up
pattern matching alright
things like level and heads and go ahead
another thing is the new allowed heads
which does separate sparse array from
list so I think it's again consistent to
be explicit and return a sparse array
when extracting the 0 part of wave it so
what's allowed heads being used for
mentions and oh that's good exactly
that's a good that's a good reason
look we need more of an inventory of
what the different sort of stakeholders
on this are okay that that's a good
reason to do so look anything that is a
head related operation so to speak um we
should be worried about what this how
this plays and aloud heads is a good
argument for having to making sure that
this thing at least for its head returns
its genuine head so to speak right
because it does distinguish least from
sputtering right but so now the question
is what depends on the zero there and
where do we you know where do we use
that zero thing right where do we use
part zero are there situations like
level for example I mean what what I
think uses part zero implicitly is map
with you know heads goes to true but the
fact is that Maps doesn't go anywhere
with these things right map doesn't do
anything with these their atomic well
map works with sparse arrays and
structure arrays it will normalize well
let's let's take a look I mean so you're
saying that if I say map
what the heck right okay oh boy
well that's it a good argument I claim
for the head being list of the thing
zero well let's see what happens if I
say map
yeah this is the test map of F onto that
sparse array this is going to tangle
it's it's it's self up heads goes to
true okay so for some reason um it
ignored the head can I do my patsy yeah
I'll do that
know what make of that
um well except that that really supports
the idea that element zero is list but
maybe it is list there because it didn't
extract of the zeroth element and it saw
that it was list
in other words this is clearly connected
to part zero of the sparse array the
behavior here and it's consistent with
that behavior I think well right
I don't know how consistent yeah it's
sort of consistent with that behavior
all right listen it's looking to me like
I am provisionally going to say that I
think the behavior that it has this with
sparse array is correct with the zero
element thing with that being list and I
think that might be true for all the
other star array type functions but
really we need to know what all the
stakeholders are what are all the
functions that could interact with this
heads allowed heads map at all those
kinds of things but that will be my
provisional conclusion
oh my gosh you know yeah and okay oh oh
my gosh why isn't that a zero length
byte array well so one answer is that
honestly I think this is wrong I think
it should be a zero length byte array
because I think that for example when
you do byte array the string there will
just be a null string I think this is
wrong yes there we go you're saying this
here's not argument why it should work
but you because because we accept byte
array as typed for libraries to pass
into the library directory but I cannot
pass a null string and now as you know
length array which is a useful thing why
not you want to be able to pass it yeah
I agree you want to be able to pass it
yeah so I think this is just a bug yeah
well but you know then it's not really
well so Rob was supposed to be here I
don't know why you know this meeting was
scheduled if he can be here can we
please try to find him can somebody find
him yeah I tried but call a cell phone
the okay what does Rob does Rob have an
objection oh god what is this would be a
big project to make this work yes why
because right now there there's only one
empty list anywhere and which is a
snowless
and so basically anywhere that we
currently allow arrays of various kinds
to go through will now need to be
prepared for a array an empty array
which is not an empty list right there's
no there's no empty Packer a there's no
empty sparse array ok listen this is a
bug
I don't know how hard it is to fix it
but this is a bug I think it's I was
talking about all of those cases not
just the byte array case an empty
America array and empty symmetrized
array and an empty sparse array I think
that's good yeah go ahead
there was an argument that other race
there maybe rectangular so they have
more than one dimensional and of zero
lengths it's not quite clear or what it
should be but byte array is always want
to mention them and well this one okay
so if I do this and I say it's a zero by
zero array what should that be oh it's
is this is the zero by zero array
different from the just single length
zero and the answer better be yes yeah
because you have different rank yeah
except we've right we've we've never had
a concept of anything other than the
innermost dimension being zero yes
that's true right but you did one zero
there you'd get a list containing an
empty list
I understand but that's different from a
0 by 0 array sure if we were to grant
the existence of such a thing okay look
so Rob has a point of view about this is
that correct
other than the point of view that oh
this is hard okay as far as I'm
concerned what the behavior is showing
here is a bug the question of whether
there should be 0 by 0 arrays I I think
that the logical chain that we have will
lead to that
you you think this is a bug for all of
these array types
I feel less strongly about it for
everything other than byte array okay
right so there's a baguette for these
other things I think per byte array it
is a full-fledged bug right which is I
guess just another indication that byte
array isn't really an array that's true
and so we probably should have called it
byte array which we'll call it right
yeah by vector byte list binary in the
wxf documentation we refer to it as a
binary string because it's you know
basically as whether things clear by at
least make something by list is a very
good name I like byte array compared to
bite list so I really an array in the
sense of all of our other arrays okay
fair enough which are in fact lists when
but by another name alright so look I
think the conclusion here we need Rob if
he's going to make a comment about this
maybe there's a way to do the byte array
case more cheaply than all these other
ones I don't really see why this is such
a big deal to do the byte array okay so
I can see these other ones might be a
bigger deal not in the kernel
necessarily cuz there are many cases but
then the other things like library link
byte array underneath is just an America
Ray so then we roll ain't sending stuff
out I mean maybe it shouldn't be just a
numeric array maybe we should fork that
code no no that's the wrong way Steve
and obviously we've been trying to unify
packed Aranea merit or a battery to make
them all the same otherwise it's
unmanageable okay and and and so they
have to be unified I mean otherwise you
scare all right okay we don't have a
person here we don't have Rob here that
was a mistake that we cannot finish this
conversation without him but my position
is that the byte array case is a bug
maybe that's because we're trying to
unify this we cannot do this or it's
hard to do again there's nothing further
to say here we don't have Rob here
we should find out why we don't have Rob
here we don't have him so we are meeting
is sabotage with respect to this and I
was on PTO for half of today so I'm
assuming this half oh I tried contacting
him in the morning it still didn't get
anything what's going on okay this is
sort of a really preliminary sort of
discussion but I don't know what this
means this is so it's a way of
representing a number with a certain
type so in numeric array we have like
you know 8-bit signed integers floating
point 32-bit numbers but we do so we
could represent a race but we can't
represent a single number with that type
in the system so doing what the America
Rey to be the container for that or do
we want something I could typed number
object or or what is the you know why
don't you try is this a big number as
there's something else no no it's a
machine number of a specific type that's
not an M integer it's not the largest
type like an M insider' and embryo M
complex it's a smaller type oh it's for
the compiler it's there all sorts of
things where you add a number to a
numeric array you want to maintain the
type it's also a limiting case like
there in total where if total returned
an M entity you've lost the information
about the fact that it came from a
binary okay this is a this is the tip of
a giant giant iceberg not resolvable on
its own this has to do with keeping
internal data representation type
information around for which we actually
have this perfectly good typed you know
blah blah blah integer mechanism right
in the compiler yeah yes but not around
the system in general that's correct
that's correct
so other people like image processing
other people we're not solving this
problem like this okay that this is a
big you know to introduce something I'm
not keen on the numeric array thing I
think it's a
low-level thing it's not intended for
particularly for general users and it
better not show up for general users I
mean you know we could go and we could
talk about every employee export format
could return random type stuff because
it happened to see that what came in was
a unsigned integer in some you know
weird random you know representation in
the outside world oh let's not put it
into an ordinary integer let's put it
into a weird unsigned you know short or
something
mm-hmm which is not what we want because
we have a giant system that does not
deal with these things and it will be it
will you know other than in the compiler
we have no way to deal with this stuff
right so what are we going to do with
these what are we going to do with them
how many functions are going to support
these everybody I like arithmetic when
it when with we're close to having
arithmetic working for numeric array so
you can add them you can do all the
sorts of operations in interpretive
low-level outside the compiler you can
you call sign abs plus times or weather
so the things that are in the runtime
library for the compiler you can do
right that's basically what you're
saying yeah okay this is this is a
subsystem of the whole language that is
specially made for the runtime library
for the compiler know my statement is
have it worked through the compiler okay
that's fine that's fine by me because
I'm just saying there are other people
around the company who would want that
kind of representation image processing
etcetera then they need to make a case
for that then they need anything is for
that I don't see why they're not storing
it in a in a numeric array what's wrong
with storing is a numeric array it's
it's okay it's a it's a you know what
you're basically saying there is this is
you know what in fact it's what you're
suggesting here but this is a numeric
array that is simply I'm a little bit
confused orientation where it's
literally a rank 0 an americorps a yeah
with no dimensions exactly
it's a rank zero America rate but we've
never done that for pact eraser so
that's why we want to discuss it with
you Steve but back to Ray is not a
user-visible thing a sure sure but it is
a departure that's all to have a rank
zero object so that is an array right so
if we have these medians which are
ranked zero and they're the only ones
that can be rank zero that'll be a
little weird too but well look why this
is I think I think the short I mean so
so so let me make one comment and one
summary I mean part of this is you know
people who are interacting with external
libraries via library link or whatever
right this is sort of an edge case for
them which is they think a large part of
right so if they want something which is
stored as a list of numbers right in our
system that should be treated as a list
of bytes for the external library this
is one way to do that although there
will be others Ethan our live stream is
asking about um compile interacting with
sparse array I thought Tom told me that
that was working now function compile
interacting with sparse arrays that in
fact working or is that not the case I
think there were some problems with the
sparse array data structure changes that
we've made that we could quite get into
this version so I'm not sure why so it's
coming soon well yeah I mean it's
scheduled so there was an issue that
this current sparse array didn't play
nice with the new compilation
capabilities yeah the form of the sparse
array we were trying to change that
before you know having it be compiled
the weather and there's a probably
changing the format some of the craft
code etc so it needs a bit more time
alright so look the concept
that there's a representation of an
individual number that is relevant for
external libraries and so on I don't
know I mean I I really object to the
phrase typed number no no I mean it's
just a suggestion do we want to do
inside the America rate which is I'm not
sure I'm not sure I'm not sure not sure
okay well then I guess the short answer
is we need to think about this more and
I think so I mean I I think that that if
you want to get it in somehow somewhere
put it inside the America array for now
but whether it should have for cosmetic
reasons a different head I'm not sure
so anything other than cosmetic reasons
for it to have a different head it just
kind of limits how it can be used so I
love the numeric array code of the month
is not prepared for these objects so it
would kind of allow it to be introduced
more incrementally but that's that's the
only one we if it was a sensor it was a
different head yeah exactly because then
you'd need to add cases specifically for
the object but like you say most thing
that that object all over the system so
it's not ideal yeah I don't think it's
great I think we should look at this
some more and and I mean it's a little
weird that numeric array can have any
dimension of array in that first
argument right mm-hmm yes can I have a
sparse array in the first argument no
okay
look I think this is what you should try
to do for now although I'm not
completely certain whether it should
have different decoration in the end
okay
I mean internally it will be that object
anyway so if I make this changes like to
the runtime library etc then
you know it has a different wrapper
that's that's easy to change later okay
next up table with symbolic arguments
well this is weird it's weird but it was
not an accident
well this needs to affect with fixed
with code assistance
I think we need to figure out how to
make this work so let's inventory what
the issues are with it so if we evaluate
the second argument is that problematic
I feel it doesn't evaluate the second
argument right now well it does evaluate
it and but it only proceeds if the
result is you know number but so there's
a side effect if there's a side effect
there it will it will evaluate it so in
other words if I say table of X comma
print foo for well that's interesting
why did it print it twice okay but
that's already kind of weird could it've
Auto compiled or done something weird
like that yes it's possible that's a
little weird we should figure out what
what's going on oh wait that wasn't a
second argument yeah I don't know what
I'm talking about okay
separate branch I mean Devon should make
a note should go track down why that why
that print it twice but that's that's a
separate issue from right
I personally think this should just work
and then we can start building up a
calculus of these things so that we can
say things like join you know I mean
there's some stuff that should work like
join table
I mean symbolically I don't see any
reason why this is this bit of a
slippery slope because I mean like for
years people have complained part for
example if you don't give an integer
argument and you give a symbolic it's a
message because they wanted a symbolic
part representation so now you do table
you'd also need a symbolic part now you
need symbolic support for operations on
these no yes and no I mean you know does
extract work with symbolic things no
right I mean just having a table that's
symbolic I mean right I mean and some
level we could just quiet the message
but I mean what does that accomplish
yeah right I mean we've used an active
of table in various places for things
like this but you know it needs to be
added case but the truth is that this
could evaluate right to the volume of an
of an RN sphere right right so it would
be a bunch of one-offs and various
functions well I'm not sure how one-off
it is I mean this is just another area
symbolic length lists are just something
we've never dealt with yet but we've
known like we've done some experimental
projects on infinite length lists we
just haven't ever you know there's a
whole calculus of symbolic length lists
that we haven't dealt with yet so I
think there are several parts mixed here
and and they have been one of the
consumers of symbolic tables in the
differentiation of symbolic of race that
they're I use an active of table
just because of this message just to
avoid this message and I think this is a
problem separate from evaluation the
main difference in my opinion from some
product is the message exactly as with
part what also has this message that
complains about symbolic second argument
and it's also part I'll just finish this
in the case of part what we did is going
to indexed which is the same somehow
somehow the symbolic version of part
which I am not a big fan of I mean I I
you know indexed might have been avoided
if we didn't have the messaging part
part X comma n but that was considered
to be too important to remove
well I mean what you're suggesting then
is that instead of table X comma n we
have something that's called symbolic
list basically perhaps at the moment as
I said I'm using in the symbolic
differentiation and there are examples
in d like in the inactive of table
when the Padma habit is
context-dependent because if you wrap
weeds around that and and give any value
then it does something different and of
course it does something different if
you give it a value and many things do
different things you give them a value I
mean you can you know list ability is
different if you give things a value
versus not in my opinion the evaluation
issues are a minor thing in comparison
with the message so what are you
proposing no no I'm not proposing
anything I'm just explaining the reasons
of what we have done so far which is try
to save the message both in table and
import
yeah well I mean clearly one thing we
could do is get rid of the message
somehow in certain cases and make table
of X comma and evaluate to a symbolic
list I'm making sense and then we have
our calculating on symbolic lists rather
than getting tangled in the middle of a
table where I mean I'm not sure if
that's right but I think the question
which would be a question more for Roger
than anybody else is you know what do we
think we could do symbolically on
arbitrary length lists and my feeling is
we probably do quite a lot of stuff but
I'm a little concerned a lot of our
functions like join in things there's a
lot of functions that sort of operate on
arbitrary headed things and might get
fairly confused by being given I don't
know so I mean look first question is
what could we do with symbolic lists
okay and then the question is if it's if
it you know we need a calculus of
symbolic list if it turns out that we
want to attach that to table of n then
we can do that but the first step is to
understand what symbolic list could do
that seemed reasonable yep a simple
solution might be to support inactive of
table and give an active of table a nice
typesetting which is another thing I'm
missing okay and then because that
that's another thing that we already
promised which could support and then if
that variable well that's fine but but
to work out the calculus of symbolic
lists it could as well be a calculus of
an inactive table exactly
but the first step is what is the
calculus of symbolic list you know if
nothing else we should put that on the
list
Devin if you can send me a message back
we should put that on the list for four
maybe I can just do it right now
um do it put it on the list for my big
list of student projects that I maintain
um you know we did a thing for um
infinite length lists right yes I have
seen that and did we do anything with it
no again it says they're too difficult
to support or if we want to do it well
we need transfinite numbers because what
do you do joining two of those infinity
lists
I don't know the isn't isn't a chap who
worked on that now working with Johann I
think he is Luis I remember is correctly
so we could we could follow up and
figure out whether but okay to what
extent did did it already use transplant
numbers or not no but of course in in
operations like joining she couldn't
proceed what do you mean he couldn't
proceed he just has joined of an
infinite list with an infinite list
gives why can't just give an infinite
list well because you have the first few
elements of one and then you have there
so imagine that you have X 1 X 2 X 3 to
X infinity and y1 y2 y y3 to Y infinity
join those two lists how would transfer
numbers help because you can have Omega
and Omega plus 1 Omega is the last
infinite of the first list and Omega
plus 1 is the first times finite number
of the second list ok so you're saying
you could do part extraction to
transplant numbers that what you mean
yeah oh boy
well that the same thing would come up
with symbolic lists if the first was a
list length a list of length n right in
the second one and it was just the X sub
I up to X sub n then you know the Omega
using Omega there seems to me to be the
same as saying consider a symbolic
length list or am I missing something
it's yes it small is the same thing it's
just that with transfinite numbers you
have to be careful with commutativity
because Omega plus 1 is not the same
thing as 1 plus Omega I'm aware I mean
it clearly you can do something like say
what's the last element in a length n
list which you can't do in the length of
Omega list what operation so for example
presumably if we say what's the length
of that list will get LF 0 yes instead
of will get a cardinal number instead
normal number if we ask for the length
correct yeah boy maybe transfinite
numbers it's only been 130 years maybe
they'll finally finally use maybe those
are a particular problem with infinite
lists so in that sense symbolic lists
are simpler because if we imagine that
the lengths are always finite I
understand I understand of course that
you could substitute and what happens if
I say table comma infinity they'll just
give an error right right thank you
presumably even if you give it to to the
65 it'll give you an error why cuz two
errors I don't know that's another bug
that should be looked into let's look at
the stack here okay
um okay so look I think it will be
interesting to look at yeah I mean the
infinite length list thing I don't know
whether that's possible to put in the
function repository I don't know how
complicated it was maybe some Devin
could you get that looked into please
yeah and then you know I think we should
ask Roger if he has opinions about
symbolic like symbolic length list
calculus I mean that's where we should
go with this you see I need to allow
arbitrary like a sequence over finite
range so like table a table of F of I
with I going from 0 to n by saying yeah
yeah that's what we're talking about
yes that's what we're talking about for
symbolic n yeah summary box data size
limit okay the I being a tie
I fit I here is that right indeed um
okay so I mean I don't know that I have
especially since you didn't like any of
my suggestions last time around they
didn't spend a great deal of time trying
to come up with what was your favorite
suggestion last time around dollar
notebook embedding limit think it should
say notebook in it do you agree that do
you agree it should say notebook I think
it should because I think it's what
where it is right yep
what size visitor cache it's not a cache
it's frayed it's the it's the point at
which you stop storing than the
expression in the notebook and gift a
little button to date another notebook
store now if there is not a lot book to
your computer or whatever it comes from
so it's it's the typesetting does not
contain the interpretation basically I
mean technically it's a tag box with
second argument false it's a little
what's that if you're faced with a link
for the byte count almost the criteria
by count notebook local storage limit
I'm okay with that
it seems to I mean if one saw that just
out in the wild one probably no woman
have some idea what it meant yet what
else do we have that's a star limit type
function we have the output size limiter
I think it's called full output size
limit mm-hmm what units is that in
that's also in bytes
in not
storage limit to many awards it's a
complicated concept think no notebook
storage limit would work just as well I
think we might consider with notebook
things is that it sounds it starts to
sound like it's a limit on the size of
the notebook mm that's why it's just at
your store it'll also well if it has the
word storage in it may be dropping local
I don't like that of book storage limit
that could be a million different things
and well I love this okay notebook
expression storage limit how about
something like that no that gives a
different idea that you somehow limit
the size of the expression that can be
shown again fair enough well I mean
clearly the you know possibly the winner
for all time longest thing notebook
expression storage size limit is correct
[Music]
about notebook automatic storage size
limit or automatic storage limit
I think it's obscure what it's storing
mm-hmm um which I mean isn't necessarily
a bad thing is it
you know encompasses more and more
things how does this relate to
persistent value and all the things that
talk about you know isn't this like a a
location for a persistent value
persistence location right but it
doesn't hmm I mean it really
unfortunately this is one of these
things where if we know what it's
talking about then when you see the name
it's like oh okay that makes sense but
if you don't have any idea what it's
talking about you see one of these names
it's like utterly obscure
I think honestly of these that this one
here has the right has the best
emotional tenor so to speak given that
you're not going to understand it the
particle storage limit mm-hmm well what
this is is it's an in notebook what
would we call that notebook and it's an
in-line thing right right so if you do
like I know sparse array of no but I'm
thinking about these names notebook
inline storage limit in line sounds very
1960s mm-hmm no no I think I like inline
better than local yeah yeah with local I
tend to think of me on like local versus
cloud or something yes whereas this is
you know just strongly suggested it
by the way of current from our live
stream from Ethan who says he discovered
that he had 23 gigabytes of local and
resource objects and would like some
management interface and I agree that
that would be desirable I mean the very
least system information should give
that information somebody's got a loose
connection there
notebook in-line storage limit I think
that's the best one it really is in line
in the sense of you know the expression
can appear sort of anywhere right it's
not it's not like output size limit
which is limiting the whole output it's
you know the objects that opt into this
all right okay fine all right let's go
for notebook and line storage unit for
now um okay I wonder I want to talk
about this question about the management
of local resources and how you know how
big they are
okay first thing is they should be in
system inflation you've got you've got
some bizarre seashell seashore something
rather certain you what what is that
bizarre noise at I it's either you or
it's Brett my headset is as a separate
mute okay so it's I I don't think you're
by the seashore but we were hearing like
what you hear but you put you know I
don't know what it is okay
well now it's okay when you talk it's
okay but otherwise we're here no because
I think that when we don't when you're
not talking is when we hear it when you
are talking we don't hear maybe it's got
some automatic gain control anyway it's
really annoying okay but but but okay
listen how are we going to get something
where you can manage I mean like like
local objects where are the places where
you can be storing things in persistence
locations
I mean does the persistence location
does that give you just one of these
goes into the local object store
somebody no but we'd really need Roman
okay let's put on our agenda for either
ILD or LCC for goodness sake you've got
to fix this stupid audio problem there
um you know for one of those to having
functions that manage the size of local
objects and other persistence locations
because discovering that you have you
know 50 gigabytes of stuff stored in the
cloud to persist something that you're
doing it will be good to know that right
so to me okay my suggestion would be
first step is it goes in system
information second step there might be
some custom functions to discover the
stuff and to manage it and for example
to delete things in the local object
store although I don't know exactly what
you can delete there I don't know where
the vocal object store is segmented into
things which say there caches and things
that don't that's another thing we
should be discussing okay so that's an
agenda for a different meeting I think
um
yeah if Anna's saying unification of
size limits would be nice like output
size cloud object size dataset displayed
Rose
yeah well at least we're calling them
star limit types of things um I don't
know what they just set displayed rose
you
I mean that's some secret option that
just controls you know how many arrows
you see no no I understand that but I
think we're making that be a non secret
option and we should check with Chris
that it is a star limit named option I
think there's a dollar version of it
which we'll want to have
okay not not something people in this
meeting know let us pick this up again
both the management of local of
persistent persistence locations and the
naming of these limits I'm concerned
that you know one approach to this is to
have some kind of giant dashboard of
system options that control all this but
I don't think that really helps us we
all serve some dollar max star
yeah aren't those mostly describing
variables as opposed to syllable
variables like you know max machine
integer and things like that
could be I don't know a strict
difference between them
um
all right I think we should wrap up here
but we've got a separate piece to take
to a different meeting right
mm-hmm okay um great I'm a fan of your
new lack of a fan a tie-in now we're not
hearing any background noise I don't
know what's going on there okay no
because I haven't really changed
anything but glad to hear it's gonna be
very different
okay good stuff thanks a lot guys
thank you to people on lives oh there
was a complaint from Ethan on the live
stream about limit failing for some
limit of an our cell value failing that
should be looked at if Devon can pick
that up and feed that to the right
people
sure that would be me and Devendra okay
okay good stuff alright see you guys
soon thank you bye bye